sur le front diplomatique cette fois-ci
Olaf scholls le chancelier allemand est
aujourd'hui en visite en Israël première
visite dans le pays depuis sa prise de
fonction on va tout de suite retrouver
notre correspondante à Jérusalem
Gwendoline de Bono bonjour Gwendoline
alors ce conflit en Ukraine oblige bien
sûr Israël à un délicat exercice
d'équilibriste j'ai envie de dire
absolument à tout d'abord elle des
centaines de milliers de ressortissants
à issus des communautés juives russes et
ukrainiennes vif en Israël ensuite
l'État hébreux entretien de bons
rapports à la fois avec la Russie et
l'Ukraine par ailleurs Israël pense à
ses intérêts stratégiques et ses
intérêts et bien il passe par ce par la
Syrie où on le sait l'État hébreu mènent
régulièrement des frappes contre le
Hezbollah et contre les positions
iraniennes avec l'accord tacite de
Moscou un diplomate nous le disait
récemment Israël n'a pas les moyens de
se mettre la Russie ado Israël essaye
donc de se poser en médiateur naphtali
Bennett le Premier ministre l'a répété
tout à l'heure tout doit être fait pour
éviter un bain de sang il est encore
temps de passer du champ de bataille au
négociation dimanche dernier
naphtalibnet a d'ailleurs rappelé il
s'est entretenu avec le président russe
Vladimir Poutine il lui a proposé et
bien de servir de médiateur entre les
deux parties proposition refusées par le
président russe par ailleurs auparavant
naphtali Bennett c'était 30 entretenu
avec le président
ukrainien vaut le démire zeelingski
selon une source que nous avons contacté
au fait de la conversation et bien le
président
ukrainien a été déçu par cet appel avec
naphtali Bennett en tant que juif je
cite c'est ce que nous disait cette
source bien volody mirzelinski a de plus
grandes attentes d'Israël et Israël et
bien ne peut pas répondre à ses attentes
Israël mesure c'est pas pour l'instant
l'État hébreux envoie notamment de
l'aide humanitaire mais pas question
pour l'instant par exemple d'envoyer
bien de l'aide de l'aide militaire